breaking tonight three people are dead
after two separate crashes on our valley
roads thank you for joining us i'm sasha
loftis the most recent a teen said to
have been hit at a centennia at
centennial and tropical in the northwest
valley this was just after noon
witnesses say the boy was in the center
median and tried to cross but was hit by
a car this morning a couple from
massachusetts was also killed at red
rock scenic loop when they lost control
and crashed those three deaths
surpassing the 100 mark now 102 in
metro's jurisdiction that's compared to
101 for all of 2020. and the two people
that died were riding in a 2021 polaris
slingshot similar to this recently there
have been several terrible crashes
involving high-end rentals
madison kimbrough joins us live near the
strip and the i-15 tonight with a
reminder as a lot of visitors there in
town this weekend and take extra caution
on those roads madison
yeah i'm here live at desert inn and
i-15 as you can see there are plenty of
cars out here zipping through now if you
are heading out tonight be careful watch
your speed and don't drink and drive so
you or someone else doesn't become
another statistic
it's up so much not just compared to
last year but on this decade we're now
on track for the deadliest year since
2007. we've seen a lot of similarities
between impairment
lack of seatbelt usage
speed
and again those are all decisions that
are being made behind the wheel by these
individual drivers
a shocking trend as nevada highway
patrol and metro report an alarming
number of vehicle fatalities this year
you have a lot of out of town visitors
and they're just distracted they have
rental cars it's not a surprise seeing
how people drive
really fast
not paying attention saturday morning's
crash in red rock a reminder of how
careful drivers need to be a couple from
out of town lost their lives after
driving too fast in a high-end sports
car it's still unclear if it was indeed
a rental we have seen the trend with
luxury rentals and people choosing to
come to our state and especially
southern nevada
and speed and that's a deadly
combination we expected that fatalities
were going to go down in 2020 with you
know everybody did people taking
advantage of the open roads
speeding driving impaired a lot more
that's definitely translating to 2021
but it's more dangerous because we have
more people on the roadways
according to the national highway safety
administration there are projecting
364 fatalities this year statewide
that's compared to last year where it
was 314.
reporting live from desert inn and i-15
madison kimbrough live local now
[Music]